probablemente ya estén familiarizados
con la noción de que el dólar
estadounidense no es equivalente al
valor de la moneda de otros países por
ejemplo el euro si vamos a viajar a
europa y solo tenemos dólares entonces
tendremos que cambiar esos dólares por
euros o si viven en europa y tienen
algunos euros quizá quieran saber a
cuántos dólares equivalen sus euros con
estos ejemplos vamos a pensar en el
concepto del tipo de cambio
esto es importante no solo si viajamos
como turistas sino que también es
importante si importamos o exportamos
cosas si por ejemplo fabricamos autos o
todas las cosas que compramos para
producir algo tienen su precio en
dólares y vendemos lo que producimos en
europa donde ganamos en euros y tenemos
que convertirlos a dólares para conocer
cuánto recibimos el concepto de tipo de
cambio es importante veamos un ejemplo
concreto de cómo es el tipo de cambio
hay muchas formas de representar esto si
alguien nos pregunta cuál es el tipo de
cambio del dólar lo primero que debemos
preguntar es con respecto a qué moneda
si nos interesa el tipo de cambio del
dólar con respecto al euro entonces
podemos
como un dólar de eeuu es igual a cuántos
euros digamos que en este momento es
equivalente a 0.87 euros otra forma de
expresar esto es decir que un euro es
igual a cuántos dólares de eeuu y si
conocemos esta equivalencia entonces
podemos calcular esta otra simplemente
dividimos ambos lados en 3 0.87 0.87
entre 0.87 nos da 1 y uno entre 0.87 da
aproximadamente 1.15 es decir que 1.15
dólares son iguales a un euro existen
varias formas de expresar esto podemos
preguntarnos cuál es el precio del dólar
de eeuu en términos del euro es decir
cuando nos costaría comprar un dólar en
términos de euros vemos esta parte de
aquí y decimos que un dólar es igual a
0.87 euros es decir 0.87 euros por dólar
de eeuu y si queremos conocer el precio
del euro en términos del dólar de eeuu
entonces haremos lo contrario
cuesta 1.15 dólares es decir 1.15
dólares por euro teniendo esto en mente
vamos a hacer algunos cálculos
imaginemos que en eeuu una caja amarilla
cuesta 20 dólares estas cajas amarillas
tienen mucha demanda alguien en europa
quiere comprar una de estas cajas
amarillas y tiene que pagar 20 dólares
pero sólo tiene euros cuántos euros
necesita para poder comprar esta caja
amarilla que cuesta 20 dólares bueno si
un dólar es igual a 0.87 euros entonces
20 dólares serán 20 veces esta cantidad
20 dólares por 0.87 euros por dólar por
cierto este es el símbolo del euro y
esto es aproximadamente igual a 17.40
euros ahora imaginemos lo contrario
digamos que existen unas cajas rojas que
solo se venden en europa por 20 euros
por ahí se encuentra un turista de eeuu
y se pregunta cuántos dólares necesitará
cambiar para poder pagar una de estas
cajas rojas que cuestan 20 euros sabemos
que un euro es igual a 1.15 dólares por
lo que multiplicamos esto por 2020
por 1 punto 15 dólares por euro nos da
23 dólares una idea relacionada con este
concepto es que las monedas se pueden
apreciar y de apreciar con respecto a
alguna otra moneda por ejemplo digamos
que el euro se aprecia con respecto al
dólar y ahora vamos a imaginar un
escenario donde el euro se aprecia con
respecto al dólar
usando esta información de aquí pues
para que esto ocurra el euro ahora debe
valer más de lo que valía al principio
debe valer más de 1.15 dólares por
ejemplo ahora vale 1.20 dólares y ahora
pensemos en un escenario en donde el
dólar se aprecia con respecto al euro en
este caso ocurre lo contrario que en el
ejemplo anterior ahora el dólar vale más
que 0.87 euros
por ejemplo 0.9 euros o un euro de forma
similar si imaginamos que el euro se
deprecia con respecto al dólar es lo
mismo que decir que el dólar se ha
apreciado con respecto al euro por lo
que si el euro se deprecia con respecto
al dólar iniciando con esta condición
podríamos decir que ahora un euro
equivale a menos dólares
y 1.05 con esto terminamos esta
introducción al tipo de cambio que puede
ser algo confuso ya que estamos hablando
del precio de una moneda en términos de
otra moneda pero los invito a que hagan
este tipo de operaciones mentales para
que se vayan familiarizando más con este
concepto si un euro vale más que un
dólar si una cosa cuesta cierta cantidad
de euros entonces la cantidad en dólares
será menor y de forma similar si un euro
cuesta menos que un dólar entonces algo
que tenga precio en dólares valdrá una
cantidad menor en euros con eso
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo